what I want to do in this video is
explore what the actual basket of goods
looks like for the Consumer Price Index
we had a ridiculously simple example in
the last video and right over here this
is a table I got this is from a press
release issued by the Bureau of Labor
Statistics so if you do a search for CPI
or CPI - you and Bureau of Labor
Statistics you should find the press
release where they issue the CPI and
this is the first table in that press
release and they say the Consumer Price
Index for all urban consumers and just
like we talked about in the last video
when people talk about the CPI index
they're really talking about or they
tend to be talking about the CPI - you
the CPI for urban consumers because most
consumers fall into this category US
city average buy expenditure category
and commodity and service group and then
they define their base year the base
year actually they have arranged maybe I
guess they take an average between 1982
and 1984 they say that is a hundred
unless otherwise noted and so what they
do in this first column so these are the
different buckets that people spend that
the urban consumer might spend some of
their money on so this is saying the
basket of goods were giving awaiting so
about a little under 15% is spent on
food and beverages and then they break
down that 15% so 13% is on food and they
even break it out between 7% or a little
under 8% is food at home and then they
break it out between cereals meats dairy
and related products fruits and
vegetables so the average based on the
way the basket looks it looks like
they're spending about the same amount
on fruits and vegetables as they're
spending on alcohol oh and they're
spending significantly less on well
that's I don't know if that's a good
trend right over there but this isn't it
that's why this is interesting to look
at because this is viewed as a typical
basket of goods for your average urban
consumer and you can see they're
spending a little bit more on meats
poultry and fish you could see the
breakdown and then you can keep breaking
it down they're spending 41% the basket
of goods on housing and they even break
that up in terms of some of it as your
primary some of it is you're kind of
just general shelter then there's stuff
like food and utility you land utilities
that is encapsulated in your housing
you're going to have to heat your home
and whatever else then your furniture
four percent or four point four percent
is spent on furniture we could keep
going down this is pretty interesting to
look at
the basket of goods so this is used as a
typical urban consumer spending 3.6% on
apparel 17% on transportation 6.6
percent on medical care and almost a
similar amount on recreation a similar
amount on education and they keep
breaking it down into all of the
different in the different categories a
little under 1% on tobacco and smoking
products and you might say well most
people don't you know these days in the
u.s. don't smoke but the ones who do
spend way more than this so this is an
average of the all of the people who all
the people united states so for example
if if one out of 10 people spent 10
percent of their income on tobacco and
the other people don't smoke at all then
you might get on average the average
basket of goods is about 1% and they
keep breaking it down into into other
things and all of these weightings
combined they will add to they will add
to 100 that is the entire basket of
goods and now what they do so this is
there's this as they're waiting this
column right over here essentially gives
us the waiting as of December 2010 and
that's going to change as people's
habits change or as new goods and
services emerge on the market or frankly
even as prices change that will change
but you have to have some weighting in
which to kind of take a weight of the
price changes or a weight to weight the
average percent changes now they told us
they told us that unless otherwise noted
our base here is going to be a hundred
and then relative to that base year they
then give us the prices the price
indices for each of these buckets in
November of 2011 and then December of
2011 and then they're going to actually
figure out the unadjusted percent change
to December 2011 from so this is year
over year from December the previous
year and this is from the previous month
and you can see the change from the
previous year is much larger than the
change from the previous month and one
way to look at this so this is saying in
November 2011 in November 2011 food and
beverages on average were about 2.3
times more expensive than they were
between 1982 and 1984 December 2012
sorry December 2011 they were about 2.3
one times more expensive than they were
in 1982 to 1984 and just as an extra
kind of data point they actually give us
this one little line here they said well
if we set 1967 is the base year then all
items so here all items if we if we use
the the default base year of 1982 to
1984 in November 2011 all items were
about two point two six times as
expensive they were in 1982 to 1984 but
if we use 1967 as our base year now it's
about six it's six point seven seven
times as expensive remember the base
here is equal to one hundred so this is
six point seven seven times as expensive
as they were in 1967 and you could go
down you could go down all of the
categories to essentially see these are
all relative to 1982 to 1984 so you can
see how much things have gotten more
expensive so it's interesting things
like furniture things like furniture
have not gotten that much more expensive
relative to the early 80s in fact there
are some categories that have even
gotten cheaper for example new and used
motor vehicles it hasn't changed much at
all since based on at least this
weighting and they do all these
adjustments based upon the quality of
the car so you might say wait I'm
spending more in my car that I did in
1982 but they're making adjustments
based on your car being that much better
and all of that so it's not exactly an
apples to apples comparison but you
could see that based on those
adjustments it doesn't look like it's
changed much things like medical care
has gotten a lot more expensive since
the early 80s four times as expensive
you see right over there video and audio
has gotten cheaper recreation in general
has not gotten that much more expensive
information and information processing
has gotten cheap or telephone service
has not gotten that much more expensive
communication has gotten cheaper and you
I don't know if you were around in the
early 80s but actually the cost to call
someone long-distance has gone down
dramatically even see personal computers
they have gotten cheaper and once again
like the auto like the cars there's an
adjustment for it for essentially they
don't do it directly because obviously
computers have gotten orders of
magnitude more powerful but kind of the
they have gotten on cheaper average and
they have gotten much much more much
more powerful but this is fun to look at
I mean you can see look at it right over
here tobacco and smoking product
has become dramatically more expensive
you have more and more jurisdictions
that are for the most part taxing it or
whatever to making it harder and harder
to buy you see things like I'm it's just
fun to look at dig around here medical
oh we already looked at this this is the
overview services durables you know a
lot of these things are in kind of this
1 to 2 to 3 price range but the stuff
like medicine tobacco much more
expensive things like computers
communications much cheaper and then as
we mentioned before this measures the
percent change to December 2011 from the
previous year so that's why it gives you
a year-over-year number and this is from
this is from the previous month and
these are seasonally adjusted changes
and if we have time in another video
I'll talk about how you can calculate or
I'll do a simple example of seasonally
adjusting things